- [Voiceover] If you
look at most substances,
so this is most things, right over here.
As we go from a liquid state
where things are literally fluid,
the molecules are moving past each other,
to a solid state, where things
are rigid or more rigid,
you typically have something
getting more dense.
So the liquid state would be less dense.
Less dense.
And the solid state would be more dense.
Would be more dense.
Let's think about what
would happen if water
were like most things here.
So imagine a body of water.
So let's say that's the
land right over here,
this is a cross section of a body of,
I don't wanna draw brown
water, I wanna do blue water.
So this is a cross
section of body of water,
like say, we see in this picture here.
Now let's say it is very cold.
That the air is extremely cold.
Let's say it's below the
freezing temperature of water.
Well what would happen is the
water up here would freeze.
And this is actually what does happen.
Water at the surface would freeze,
but if this ice were more dense,
the solid water were more
dense than the liquid water,
well then the ice would sink.
The ice would sink and
collect at the bottom.
The ice would collect at
the bottom right over here.
And then the water over
here would freeze again.
It would freeze again.
But if that were more
dense, then it would sink
and collect at the bottom.
And you keep going with this
process on and on and on,
and eventually the entire body of water,
the entire lake would freeze solid.
Would freeze...
It would freeze solid.
Now you can imagine this
wouldn't be that good
for the animals that
are living in the water.
If you imagine some fish in here.
Those fish would then freeze.
And most living things, there
are a few simple organisms
that can survive being frozen.
But most living things would just die.
And so this would not
be a good environment
for animals to live in, or for
even biology to take place.
But what's neat about water,
it does not follow this pattern.
When we're talking about water,
when we're talking about water,
when we go to the liquid state,
when we go from liquid water to solid ice,
to solid ice, we actually get,
we actually get less dense.
So this right over here is less dense.
This is why ice floats.
This is more dense, more dense.
And this is less dense.
And to think about why
that is, it all goes back
to the hydrogen bonding.
So we've seen in previous videos.
So, I'm gonna do it all in one color.
Oxygen, hydrogen, hydrogen.
Let's say this is the liquid
state that I'm drawing
right over here.
This is liquid water.
Liquid water.
So then you have oxygen,
and you have oxygen and hydrogen
and hydrogen.
And you have oxygen and hydrogen
We've already talked multiple times
about the fact that you have partial
negative charges at the side
away from the hydrogens.
Partial negative, partial negative
because oxygen is so electro-negative.
And you have partial positive charges
on the hydrogen ends.
Partial positive charges at the hydrogens
and these partial negatives
and partial positives
attract each other and this
is called hydrogen bonding.
Now the liquid state,
you have enough energy.
The temperature is just
really average kinetic energy
that these molecules are
able to bounce around
and flow past each other.
These hydrogen bonds get broken
and get reformed over and over again.
These things flow past each other
and also they have enough energy
to kind of push even closer to each other
than even the hydrogen
bonds would dictate.
Sometimes they go closer,
sometimes they're further,
sometimes they're pushing around.
But as we get--
As we get cooler, as we get
cooler and we lose heat,
then they don't have the kinetic energy
to kind of--
They get closer and bump
up against each other
and move right and flow
right past each other
and they form a lattice structure
where it will look more like this.
Where it will look like oxygen,
hydrogen, hydrogen, oxygen, hydrogen,
hydrogen, oxygen, hydrogen, hydrogen.
And so you actually have the molecules
being further apart from each other
because they don't have
the kinetic energy,
once again, to keep breaking and reforming
these hydrogen bonds, or even to kind of
have the kinetic energy to
push up against each other.
And so you form this lattice structure.
You could even have another oxygen.
And I'm obviously drawing
it in two dimensions,
but ice, things in our universe,
in our reality are three dimensions.
But hopefully this gives you the
big picture of it.
Oxygen, hydrogen, hydrogen.
And so you have these hydrogen bonds.
I wanted to do those in white.
These hydrogen bonds.
And remember, these hydrogen bonds,
they're still, it's still the case,
electrons are still moving around,
and so you still have a partial
positive charge here and
partial negative charge there,
but there's not enough
kinetic energy to push
them close to each other
and flow past each other
and so you have ice right over here.
You have solid water.
You have ice over here being less dense.
And this is what keeps ice floating,
this is what keeps icebergs floating,
this is what keeps lakes like this
from freezing solid.
This is why the surface freezes,
but you have water below it.
In fact, that ice on the top protects
the water below from...
You can imagine, the ice, it protects it
from getting even further frozen
and so you have animals
able to just hang out.
Hang out down here and
go through the winter and then
everything will thaw once you get to
the spring and the summer.